let's talk about the the the more um
what's the right word terrifying result
of everything we've done in this
i'm i'm going to say it and people might
get mad it actually is a kind of funny
video as much as it is horrifying now
i'm scared taliban appear to fly u.s
blackhawk helicopters over kandahar
the afghan air force reportedly had 167
operational aircraft including 33
blackhawk attack helicopters before the
taliban took over and there's a video
you may have seen it of the taliban
literally flying around in blackhawks
there's like a guy hanging from it and
there's this one this one twitter
account of the taliban they're tweeting
like trying out our new weapons and
stuff like this the us
just gave one of the most advanced
militaries
not an air force and and ground forces
to
ideological extremists
who who beat us back with basically
rocks and sticks
that's that's that's the amazing thing
like what's the goal of the americans
like how can we funnel a bunch of
weapons to these people
it was we're gonna leave these weapons
for the afghani allies it really was but
we're gonna strip all their support out
and they're just gonna figure it out and
then the afghani allies were like uh no
we're not because we can't well but we
also gave them we also gave all those
afghan allies the option of leaving
right i mean we facilitated in the past
couple of weeks or whatever we
facilitated a massive brain drain from
that country how do we expect it to ever
stand up for itself after we basically
said to all of the educated people there
why don't you just come here why don't
you abandon your responsibility to your
own nation and come to a nation that
we're already destroying that that's
that's that's really the craziest thing
to me seeing so many people be like
i don't care about this place i'm
leaving right you know
okay why would we why were we trying to
help a nation where the peop the
brightest people in the country didn't
care about it because they were winning
no no no yeah yeah yeah i was going to
say uh these people
were not raised you know a lot of them
are young like the one guy who who got
on the plane and then died i think is
what 19 years old right the soccer
player so he was born into occupation
right he has no sense of country no
community so when it all comes crashing
down he's like that's what i i recognize
and i don't know what that is so i'm
going with that right so the united
states did a very very poor job of
culture building and you know what's
funny well we shouldn't be culture
building somebody else's culture well no
no no for sure we shouldn't have been in
there in the first place
the point is if you want an operation
like this to be successful to like
create a stable country whatever you've
got to give people stories and things to
rally around and victories and and
something like you know we have this
story of the of the writing of the
star-spangled banner where like the
bombs are exploding and then every time
a bomb blasts you could see the flag
just as the light of the explosions and
then when they came back to the fort
what did they find the dead bodies of
the american soldiers who were running
in and holding the flag up and their
bodies formed the base that kept those
are the stories that people are like a
shed a tear like yes we did it they
don't have any of that we even have
cultural stories though i mean if you
think about it uh during the cold war
you know the ussr was our big enemy and
how did we infiltrate the ussr we you
know americans and
europeans would go there with suitcases
full of blue jeans and beetle stapes
we infiltrated culture from the bottom
and from the side and from the angle
they make the blue jeans illegal
you'll literally be killed in public if
you're listening to music in public and
you know i think that that's something
that america forgets is our best
offerings are not our you know
administrative level
things our best offerings are our
culture and we are undermining that too
at every
turn in the united states we are
undermining our own culture it's falling
apart
i think for the most part uh the
uniparty is absolutely to blame these
people have no idea how countries are
run
politics is downstream from culture yeah
and so the republicans clearly do not
understand this when they're like we got
so many judges in yeah and then the
judges are like political pressures
forced me to go in the direction of
mainstream culture also once you're in
court you lost it doesn't matter what
the victory is i gotta say
this 21st century war because this is
both the points you guys are making with
the new age of military and the way it's
done with the internet you don't send
troops to a country nation building you
don't take put a soldier on every block
and every window so that they can't get
from place to place you basically are
controlling the system because they have
facebook groups they can coordinate on
the internet now putting troops in a
foreign country to nation build is not
the tactic anymore and if anything that
i've learned from the vets that are
coming back there it's that you did not
fight in vain you fought to teach us
that in a modern war we cannot be
putting boots on the ground to build
nations it has to be through the
internet except when you can't get
internet in there either because of the
mountainous regions of the country or
because the ideological extremism yeah
which is my point about what's happening
here in the u.s they spent so much time
worrying about afghanistan and iraq and
iran in between that they ignored the
fact that the u.s itself is being
overrun by a psychotic cult of people
and i'll tell you i love i love the idea
of the cult you know why because i saw
this post about horse dewormer on reddit
okay
listen and the people in the commented
like it's a death cult and i'm like bro
if you actually did two seconds of
google searching you would realize that
certain medications which uh you know
are widely available at walgreens but
for some reason the media keeps saying
horse dewormer over and over because you
are in the matrix
and so here we maybe that's what they're
thinking they're like i don't know let's
have a dumb population that'll allow us
to flourish no it won't a bunch of
people who have no idea what's going on
who can't make any decisions and perhaps
you think that'll empower you but it
guts the country from the inside it's a
brain drain happening in our own country
we've done it on purpose i mean we did
it on purpose because we had these
ideals of what we should be doing
instead of the thing we were doing so
we've gutted our educational system
we've completely devalued the college
degree we've devalued graduate degrees
we've devalued diplomas we don't learn
anything in schools at this point we
don't teach anything you know um
i imagine unironically thinking college
is a good idea
right yeah or unironically saying
college is a good idea what i mean i'm
sure that i have a similar experience to
you guys when i was a kid my parents
were like you know you're definitely
going to college
and i'm looking at my son and i'm like
if you want maybe
you could go to state
oh i'm totally different from you i'd be
like no yeah make sure you under
understands uh compound interest
i'm telling him you know like the money
i have saved for you you could also just
buy some property if you want you know
you could travel start a business at 14.
you could do whatever you want with this
you could read you could read on your
own on the internet which is now free
and learn how to discern between real
and fake news and then teach yourself
because there are a lot of prominent
young people or young people today who
are older but rose to prominence when
they were young because they just went
online and there's some famous stories
about young hackers or like you know
let's say tech entrepreneurs and when
they were 15 years old on the internet
in forums contributing code the other 30
year olds taking that code had no idea
was a 15 year old contributing right and
so there's a real opportunity to get
away from that broken system but i do
think there's a lot at the end of the
tunnel though with the with the the
coming collapse
remote working means you'll be around
your kids more often right that is a
that is a plus and remote schooling
means the parents are more likely to be
near their kids when their kids are
learning and to see what's actually
being taught right the cto of mine is
pretty important he was 17 when he
started working with minds i mean you
can do it young you do not need school
this is the big thing why we talk about
the cass castle vlog we've been doing
and building culture and trying to bring
more people here
that's so important that's like the most
important thing is storytelling you know
remembering the old stories i think
that's a big part of it too the more we
replace the canon with things that we
think you know are
contemporarily important
the more we undermine what our culture
is founded on there's a really
interesting we have to go back to the
old stories there's a really interesting
kind of similarity between some of
what's happening with the taliban flying
around in blackhawks and what's
happening in the u.s we have ideological
zealots who have taken over the new york
times for instance and so now they're
wearing it like a skin suit and that we
see that with so many different
franchises and movies that's reclined at
the new york times we've seen that what
what did he do he's just you know he's
writing these columns all the time that
are just supporting the administration
without any real reason or jennifer
rubin today at the washington post
where she was like
the us is still the
the only superpower and it's like girl
if you got to say that we're already in
trouble but so so
the new york times this powerful
institution of you know 100 plus years
or whatever now being worn as a skin
suit by these ideologues
american military power and air force
supremacy with the blackhawks now being
worn by an ideological extremist group
that's you have have seized control of
this infrastructure how many missiles
i'm not saying it's identical i'm just
saying they're not going to tell you how
many missiles they left they're not
going to tell you how much equipment did
they see did you see this taliban's new
arsenal graphic was anyone able to yeah
there were some graphics yeah but i
couldn't twenty two thousand figures
this says it's from the us government
accounting office oh interesting what
country is due west of afghanistan that
would be iran and do you think that when
everything starts falling apart in
afghanistan and they need electricity
and infrastructure and resources do you
think they might say hey iran look at
the 42 000 suvs we have might you need
some of this yes i think we have some
hellfire missiles sitting right here in
this building we can't do anything with
them i think you know what we do need is
electricity well and iran is uh pretty
close a lot closer to nuclear
capability now at this point anyway i'm
i'm willing to bet the moment
they took a couple like i'm i'm willing
to bet a phone call was made the moment
donald trump signed that peace treaty
with iran was immediately like give me
you know like what do you got what are
we gonna do but i'll tell you this there
may have been some phone calls back and
forth back then
the moment word got out that bagram was
abandoned that all of this equipment was
abandoned
iran called up and said you know call it
the teleman said buddy hey how you been
the most popular who's always been there
for you what do you think would have
happened if the u.s had left on trump's
timetable
uh it's it's not so much about the
timetable it's about the the caliber of
leadership right
i'm wondering like how that would have
been
if it would have been any different
biden has said repeatedly that he
doesn't think it would have been any
different well he says i think he's
wrong too
it would have been it would it would
have been similar a little more
organized perhaps it's not so much about
the timeline it's the bigger question is
what would have happened if biden stuck
to the arrangements and agreement set
forth set forth by the trump
administration how about this why did
they abandon bagram overnight yeah
because they easily could have said
we're evacuating out of pocket why
didn't they evac why didn't they do a in
april i've i haven't factored this but
i've seen some reporting in april the us
issued a warning to american citizens
you need to get out right now a lot of
americans stayed chose to stay and that
is true but i don't think it's as easy
to say that americans were like well
they're choosing to stay that's their
problem well it's probably like there's
people there trying to help and won't
leave behind right and so that means the
u.s need to have a hard extraction like
come on get your stuff we are leaving
you can't stay uh it's tough though
americans do have a right to choose to
stay in the comments on private
contractors or whatever but i believe
if they stuck to the original plan the
and and i'll tell you this it's it's
more to do with the leadership than just
the plan but if the original plan was
stuck to i don't think this would have
happened i think the taliban would have
absolutely tried moving forward and then
there would have been some very serious
drone strikes drones striking moving
militants through the desert heading to
provincial capitals is a lot easier than
doing a drone strike on residential
houses in kabul which just killed a
bunch of kids yeah i i think that
there's also um something to be said for
sticking to the plan that your
predecessor laid out because
america's word is now garbage we made a
deal and then we were just like meh yeah
but the taliban hold on i feel like
that's a that's a problem like what's
the tax regardless of whether or not you
know the taliban would have stuck to
their end the u.s once once the us makes
a deal like we should stick to that it
shouldn't matter who's in power the
taliban broke the deal
right i'm sorry i'm sorry i take that
back biden broke the deal yeah
we should have said we should have like
you know as soon as he got into office
he should have said something like
if this was the view i don't think we
should leave right away but we said we
would so i'm going to honor
the word of the united states yeah i
feel like he didn't do much about it in
the early days of his presidency yeah he
didn't do anything except reverse
trump bans on critical race theory you
know he spent days
reversing executive orders
instead of actually you know and getting
masses of praise for that i could see
like months and months where they did
not do anything about evacuation even
though they knew they had the timetable
because in the back of his mind he was
like f trump that guy's i'm not paying
attention that guy whatever i'm not
right i'm focusing on this and he had
months to prepare for this well and i
think he also had this completely
backwards idea that the entire rest of
the world thought that trump was as
illegitimate as the current
administration thinks trump was but in
fact that wasn't the case whether our
allies or enemies or whatever liked or
didn't like trump he was the
legitimately elected president and he
was treated that way as well he should
have been and his bilateral agreements
you know were the word of the united
states whether biden liked them or not
so when he came in he kind of acted like
oh the past four years i can just you
know completely sweep them under the rug
and get rid of everything that happened
during that period of time because
everyone knows that that was an
illegitimate presidency and that was
completely bonkers and and a slap in the
face of the american public that voted
for the previous administration thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you